♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IS A BASIC MORAL
PRINCIPLE THAT WAS FOR A LONG
TIME CONVENTIONAL WISDOM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU PROBABLY GREW UP WITH IT.
IT WAS THIS.
PEOPLE WOULD DESERVE TO BE
TREATED AS INDIVIDUALS JUDGED BY
THEIR OWN EFFORTS ON THEIR
ABILITIES ON THE THINGS THEY CAN
CONTROL.
THAT WAS THE STANDARD AND FOR A
LONG TIME ALMOST EVERYBODY IN
AMERICA BELIEVE IT, OR CLAIMED
TO BELIEVE IT.
NOT ANYMORE.
NOW IN THE LEFT IT'S ACCEPTABLE,
EVEN ENCOURAGED, TO ATTACK
PEOPLE BASED SOLELY ON THEIR
SKIN COLOR.
YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO SAY THE
THING ABOUT IT BUT SUDDENLY IT'S
MEDIA COMPANY UNIVISION.
IT'S NOT SOME OBSCURE HATE SITE
LOOKING ON THE DARK CORNERS OF
THE INTERNET.
IT'S CONSIDERED A MAINSTREAM
DESTINATION.
IT'S GOT 8 MILLION VISITORS A
MONTH SUPPORTED BY HUGE
THAT WERE JUST PUBLISHED.
"WHITE PEOPLE NEED TO BE BETTER
PEOPLE."
"FIVE LIFE X WHO WANT TO MAKE
WHITE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE AT
WORK."
WE NEED A RESET BUTTON FOR
SOMETHING FOR WHITE PEOPLE.
IF THERE ARE PLENTY MORE JUST
LIKE THAT, YOU CAN GOOGLE IT IF
YOU WANT.
AT THE A PRETTY CLEAR INTENT TO
WITH CERTAIN GENES.
IMAGINE A NEWS WEBSITE THAT
TRIED TO RANK THE MOST USELESS
TYPES OF FILL IN THE BLANK
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
WOULD TOYOTA ADVERTISE ON A SITE
THAT RAN A PIECE LIKE THAT?
OF COURSE NOT.
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO ALONE.
TAKE A LOOK AT BUSBY, ONE OF THE
MOST POPULAR WEBSITES IN
AMERICA.
IN 2016 THAT COMPANY IS VALUED
AT 1.5 BILLION.
SIX TIMES WHAT JEFF BEZOS PAY
FOR "THE WASHINGTON POST" A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
JUST LAST WEEK, JUST LAST WEEK
WAS FEED PUBLISHED A PIECE
ENTITLED "37 THINGS WHITE PEOPLE
AMERICA.
IT IS NOT JUST WRONG, IT'S NUTS.
IT'S ACTUALLY SUICIDAL.
AS THEY ARE ALWAYS CORRECTLY
REMINDING US, AMERICA IS A
MULTIRACIAL SOCIETY, WHICH IS
GREAT.
MULTIRACIAL SOCIETIES ARE GREAT.
BUT THEY ARE FRAGILE, ALWAYS.
THE ONLY SURVIVE WHEN PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT RACES DECIDE TO TREAT
EACH OTHER AS HUMAN BEINGS
WITH EQUAL DIGNITY.
WHEN THEY SQUARE OFF INTO
WARRING TRIBES IT'S OVER.
LIBERALS SAY THEY ARE POOR WHITE
NATIONALISM AND THEY SHOULD, BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THEY ARE
PROMOTING IT LIKE THIS.
WHEN LIBERALS PULL UP THE SPEED
FOR THE LATEST LIST OF WHY WHITE
PEOPLE ARE WRECKING AMERICA,
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT IT DOESN'T
AFFECT THEM.
THE JOKE LOOKS A LOT DIFFERENT
WHEN YOU WERE NOT REACHED.
YOU'VE LOST FAMILY FRIENDS TO
HEROIN, YOU HAVEN'T PAINTED YOUR
HOUSE IN 20 YEARS.
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW IS BEING
CRUSHED BY THE RISING COST OF
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE.
YOU'RE FAIRLY CERTAIN YOUR KIDS
ARE GOING TO MAKE EVEN LESS THAN
YOU ARE WORRIED, AND YOU SHOULD
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN AND THE PRIVILEGE IT
CONVEYS.
HOW MUCH OF THAT ARE YOU GOING
TO TAKE BEFORE YOU EXPLODE AT
THE UNFAIRNESS OF IT ALL?
AT THAT POINT, WHY WOULDN'T YOU
EMBRACE A RACIAL IDENTITY?
EVERYBODY ELSE SEEMS TO BE DOING
IT.
THAT'S A DISASTER, AND IT'S NOT
THEORETICAL, BY THE WAY.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THIS COUNTRY UNLESS PEOPLE START